[Music]
hi welcome I'm Jamie wax and we're in
the CBS this morning Toyota green room
with Kurama Brown one of the stars of
the Netflix smash hit queer eye
Carano is out with a revealing new
memoir that covers a wide range of
topics including fatherhood colorism and
his own struggles with addiction and
abuse welcome Kurama thanks for being
are you kidding me I'm happy to be here
you have a lot of fans here at CBS Gale
king was in here just a minute he was
that was very sweet I was honored to
meet her you've met some really
impressive people in the three seasons
of queer I I would imagine I have I have
but I think these stories that I and the
people that I love meeting is what we do
on the show like meeting everyday people
because a lot of times people who are in
the entertainment astray they have their
struggles but they have a lot of support
around them to usually get through it
but I just love meeting those everyday
people who I can connect with on another
level
you picked a period of time about 14
years almost to be an everyday person
between your reality show services a lot
of people will remember you from 2004
season of the real world adelphia that
was not a great experience for you
you're right about this it was it wasn't
it was like not a great experience it
was just that I didn't have the tools to
handle something like that you know to
be on reality television and especially
that type of reality show you have to be
able to know how to manage conflict and
be able to express yourself and so I was
a young 22 year old so anything that
happened to me I felt triggered I was
screaming you know that's why I got the
nickname crazy Kurama back then because
it was like I'm just gonna say whatever
I'm feeling because I don't know how to
really process my emotions and like what
I show in my book is how if I can go
from that erratic young person to
someone who's done the work on
themselves to find a space of clarity of
purpose for their life then anybody else
can do it because I was pretty much a
lost cause in many cases but even though
you describe that experience that way
you were an important figure for a lot
of young gay people who were watching
the show did that give you a taste of
how you could have impact when you use
television and the sort of
I'm gonna tell you not at first you know
when I went on the show is 22 I wanted
to see how much booze I can drink in one
hour I'm not gonna pretend like I went
on there like let me spire people but
then after I got the show is when I
realized wow there was a group of LGBTQ
people who had never felt seen and me
being myself gave them a sense of that
they could do it that they could be
whoever they wanted to be and that was
pretty powerful was also very
overwhelming it was one of the catalysts
of me getting heavy into drugs because
it was like all of a sudden you're
thrust from going to the grocery store
no one knowing you two young people
calling you and saying you're my hero
you can't mess up you can't do this and
I'm like I'm young like I still have
room for to make my mistakes but now I'm
appreciative of it I'm glad that I was
visible I'm glad that I had this
platform because I'm never going to stop
using this platform to try to inspire
people to have better lives you do write
about your addiction about abuse and
things like that why are you chosen to
be so candid in this memoir well I don't
think I don't think it does anyone any
favors for me to sugarcoat or hide parts
of my life if I really want to help
people to heal to grow to have purpose
then I have to show them all the parts
of my life and I'm also an open book I
think honesty and transparency is best
because that way no one can ever be like
well I remember when you were doing this
you know what I mean but some of the
subjects like you know domestic violence
it was really important for me to talk
about because not only was there history
of it in my family and I wanted to show
people that some of the burdens you sort
of take on from your childhood stick
with you you know my father was abusive
to my mother and I learned not to hit
women but I'm a gay man and in our
culture we tell young boys if you have a
problem it's okay to fight two boys
fighting it's just guys letting it off
we're getting you know getting through
whatever they're working through their
issues but I'm in a relationship with a
man so when I have anger you know I've
been sort of conditioned by society that
it's okay for me to hit another man
and I want to open up and be honest and
say listen I was in an abusive
relationship where I was the abuser
because I saw it but also because
society never gave me the tools of how
to handle this and in the LGBT community
domestic violence is actually more
prevalent than in straight couples mmm
but it's something that's never talked
about a lot of that goes to the fact
that police aren't trained properly
nurses are trained properly people and
social services aren't trained properly
to deal with same-sex couples so they
sort of just you know wave it off I
remember I used there was a time I had
been abusive to a boyfriend
and I've since apologized to him and we
are now friends but I was really abusive
I mean it was really bad - the fact that
he called the police and I sat there
arrogantly at the front door waiting for
them why because I knew when they got
there they would see two men and they
would just say oh you guys handle it and
that's exactly what they did this is the
2000s we're talking about this is like
2006 you only mean so this is not that
long ago and I still know people today
who I've helped through their domestic
violence issues who are still having
that same response for police officers
Wow you you're very forthcoming about a
lot of things that you've been through
and and you own a lot of mistakes you've
made it actually you talk about which I
found very inspiring in the book about
repurposing mistakes to make them
opportunities yeah
for for growth for love for happiness
one of those examples of course is is
your surprise entry into fatherhood at
26 years old yeah you got probably the
biggest surprise of your life yeah you
know I appreciate you saying about how I
repurpose these challenges because I
always say that failure isn't the
opposite of success as part of it you
needed to plant those seeds and use so
that you can learn and grow and blossom
to who you want to be and when I found
out I was a father I was young and there
was not one part of me that ever thought
I'd be a father it was the last girl I
did in high school I was 15 after we had
our intimate moment which only happened
once I immediately was like I'm okay I'm
done with that like you know like we can
still be friends but I don't want to do
that again and she moved away and this
is before what we know
technology so when she moved I never
knew how to contact her again and to
find out years later that I had a child
I had a lot of anger I had a lot of
sadness I had a regret I had fear I was
like what I ruined a bunch of people's
lives i internalized all of this I was
like do I have the tools to handle this
how am I gonna deal with her as a
co-parent there was all these questions
swirling em can I get my life together
enough to raise him I'm still a child
and what I learned was when presented
with that at first of all saved my life
and gave me a more purpose to realize
you're not just living for you
you're living for somebody else and I
sort of take that same message to what
my career is but it also helped me to
realize that if I really am honest about
what I'm doing honest about what I'm
feeling
talking about it getting asking for help
then I can tackle and handle any
situation and now my kids because I
adopted his my other son and they have
the same mother
my kids are help happy healthy 18 22 and
I talked about how I figured out how I
could be better in that book in my book
and I hope other people will learn that
as well what is the biggest thing
fatherhood has taught you that you
really gotta know how to communicate not
only got custody of your son but you
adopted his half yes you got to know how
to communicate and also about being an
empathetic listener you know I already
knew that but you got to be able to like
as parents you want to come in you want
to solve a problem immediately you wanna
you know best you know mom daddy knows
best mommy knows best but that's
sometimes children know what's best for
their life and you have to respect the
fact that they're young people with
brains that are working and you have to
give them an opportunity in your
guidance to express what their desires
are and I'm not talking about like I
want this or want that but like if
there's a choice that they would like to
make for their life you have to give
them an opportunity speak up for
themselves instead of stifling their
voice stifling their dreams and that's
something that I had to learn along the
way that I don't always have to solve
their problems I can just be there to
listen
and help guide and give them the tools
so they can solve their own your own
life and your own vision for your life
as a young man really a lot of stuff has
come true you had an Instagram post
recently where you showed a vision board
yeah that you put together and it's it's
amazing it's like ticking off these
things including writing a book yes all
of these things underneath writing a
book says New York Times bestseller so
please help everyone I like and I say
that like not an arrogant or like you
know like egotistical way or I'm just
really like this is my dream and I put
my dream out there for people to see and
a lot of times it's hard to say to
people this is my dream and this is what
I want and please help me along my
journey and I'm gonna be honest and I
wrote this book to help people to heal
people to give them some support by
sharing my own intimate you know stories
from my life but I also wrote it because
this has been a dream of mine since day
one and you know now that this is out
I'm just hoping people will really go
out and buy it and get it
this period we discussed between 1213
years between reality shows you say here
that you were working on yourself how
important was it to sort of step back
from from this sudden spotlight every
single person should step back and work
on themselves daily not just at the
point where it's you know once a year or
what something tragic happens every
single one of us has felt some moment
today where we're like I'm doing the
same mundane job I didn't really talk to
my wife or my husband before I left
about something I'm not facing some fear
I'm having there could be something with
my health I'm ignoring every single
person needs to take a moment out of
their day and check in with themselves
and put themselves first I take that
whole adage that we have on airplanes
put your mask on first before you put it
on anyone else and I think a lot of
times as we go through our days we think
we're putting our mask on first but
we're not we're still running around
trying to make our jobs happen do this
do that and it's it's for everyone else
but us you know you when you made that
return in queer I in the reboot of queer
I and it got so much attention you
that happy with how you came off or what
the sort of the the narrow sort of
channel they were putting you into as
far as the culture expert on the show
when you saw season one is that right
yes that is I've only seen season one
one time I couldn't watch it past that
because I felt embarrassed
I remember watching with my kids and I
was thinking this is a great show but
the what I remember my kids being like
this is what you just spent the past
couple of months doing putting together
photo albums you know and it really hurt
my heart it was like oh my gosh and I'm
thinking like no I went there and I
really did help people emotionally grow
and have you know real heartfelt
conversations but because culture
originally in the show was the guy gave
out tickets being a Broadway star yeah
the nightclub to go to I was like I
didn't come home with that purpose I
came in literally to help people have
the hard conversation with themselves
and with other people don't focus on
their emotional health and the mental
health but because it was a visual show
it was like well we have to see some
visual component and so the visual
component then ended up making it versus
the long conversations and you see
glimpses of it and it wasn't anything
that the network was I'm gonna be clear
about that no one at the network or no
one of the executive producers weren't
saying this is what you have to do I
felt the pressure because of what the
expectation was from what the last show
was and I realized once I had a
transparent conversation with them
saying hey I'm on here because I just
want to fix the inside they were like
why did you say that from day one like
we can cut out all the other stuff like
hey you don't need to be making albums
and I was like oh thanks they're like we
never thought you could build a website
you said you'll just do it because you
want and I was like oh my gosh was a big
lesson to me of like opening up and
communicating what I wanted and what I
desired and when I was going after I was
sabotaging it nobody else was and then
once I communicated about it it's like
it started to change and you saw that
shift in season 2 and season 3 is coming
out and you completely see a shift
there is none of that anymore you I mean
and I'm just so happy because now
there's a clear focus on mental health
instead of this subconscious thing that
people are picking up on people know I'm
there to help people's mental health and
emotional health your connection with
people that that you all makeover
internally externally you actually don't
make over make better so that's right
but your connections with them have led
to some of the most emotional moments of
the series can we expect a lot more of
that it's all hundred-percent I think if
you cry if you thought you cried every
time I came on screen before trust and
believe there's a lot of Tears and I'm
proud of that because the thing is a lot
of times people don't have the cathartic
moment so you know as a society we tell
men hold your emotions in I remember
there was this time I was playing
football and I just hurt myself I mean I
was in so much pain and my coaches
screaming Brown shake it off run it off
and I'm like I am basically bleeding
like my leg is like twisted the wrong
way and I remember on the track there
was a young woman that was running I'm
doing hurdles and she tripped and she
scratched her knee and everybody went
around her I was like oh my gosh can we
help you
let me feel as well and I think a lot of
times we tell men not to feel we tell
women in corporate America in the world
if you feel then all said it makes you
not a boss you know you're you're not as
strong and I'm like enough of that so
the fact that I can have these moments
with people on camera where I'm like no
you get to feel and you don't have to
apologize for it and you get to use that
emotion to grow and to heal that's what
this is all about and that's why I wrote
the book because it's a continuation of
what I'm already doing on queer I well
we're looking forward to that season 3
premieres March 15 March 15 yeah that's
exciting and the book is that now Kurama
my story of embracing purpose healing
and hope Kurama ground thanks for
joining us thanks to all of you
[Music]